Let's go to our caller from the 7 0 8 area
code caller from 7 0 8.
What's your name?
Where are you calling from?
Hi there, Gwen.
Calling from St. Louis.
Hey.
Good.
What's up, Glenn?
I'm just wondering.
You said it is still you think that the United
States is doing a worse on the car virus situation.
Wondering if you still think that even though
a lot of European countries have a higher
death rate and I know we're on a per capita,
not do as great testing volume, but we are
doing better than France, I believe.
And when you put that statement, ours targeted
to use how you would actually being, do you
have to be worse than China when China was
the one who let it spread and kind of lied
to the World Health Organization?
Do you want to go into our Trade Center?
They lied, but kind of seem like they probably
would have the worst handling out of any country.
Okay.
I gotcha.
Please, please try to keep the phone a little
further from your mouth because you are clipping.
So there's a lot of different stuff there
that you mentioned.
So let's let's let's step back for a little
bit.
One thing is I in my if you're referring to
my tweet, I actually said we don't know the
truth about the situation in China.
So it's hard to compare our response to China's
response because clearly China has not been
honest about it.
So I made that caveat.
So I don't think that they they are kind of
in the worse than a bear.
If we know they're not being true about it,
then it's spread from there.
I don't know what the truth is of the Chinese
response because we just don't know.
They're certainly being dishonest that we
can say I don't know exactly how bad the response
has been in terms of other countries.
It's becoming very clear that Russia and Brazil
are doing very, very poorly.
They seem to have benefited early from the
fact that it came first to the U.S. but Russia
and Brazil's curves are disastrous.
So by the time it's what's difficult about
this is that the outbreak started at different
times.
So we're not necessarily comparing apples
to apples, but Brazil and Russia, by the time
it's all said and done, may certainly be up
there.
But one of the things we can start to look
at is the duration of the curve before you
start seeing dramatic decreases in cases and
deaths.
And certainly when you look at places like
Spain and Italy, I mean, South Korea at the
very top of the list, Taiwan, these are places
that sometimes in a matter of 10 or 14 days
reversed the curve, whereas we are now going
on, you know, multiple months.
There are states that are now having huge
growth rates like Texas and others.
So I you know, I'm not saying the U.S. response
has been the worst.
It's certainly been of the worst.
I so I disagree with that.
I was so wondering, do you see.
It seemed like when I thought their tweets
are shows, you're saying it was the worst?
It's one of the words and I was going to be
curious about what country we can definitively
say was worse.
Iran may have been worse.
For example, China.
I mean, we're doing better.
We're doing better testing per capita.
But our death rate in France.
OK, so we're right now we're 40th in testing
per capita, so we can certainly find countries
and say we're better on this metric than that
country that we can certainly do.
But I don't know what that gets us necessarily.
Nogami, I guess I'm just saying, like, if
I mean, what what metric would you say you're
just looking at the metric of rising rates
of who's doing Brevik, who's doing like what's
doing better.
So there's a whole bunch of different stuff
that you would look at.
And Glenn, I mean, really got an easy to keep
the phone further from your mouth because
the sound really closing up.
So we look at a lot of different things.
We look at how long after the first case did
testing get up to a certain level per capita?
We were terrible on that.
We look at death rate.
Our death rate is the 12th or 13th highest
in the world.
You look at testing per capita, we're 40th
It's like there's a whole bunch of different
stuff that we look at.
There's not just one metric.
Okay.
Where you are.
I agree.
Using more than 1 metric, I guess I would
say from the Bible and I just I for the numbers
we see, we're in the middle.
But I think it's also hard to compare a country
to a country because not every country is
basically the same.
Well, our death revisit our diary doesn't
read.
All 7 percent of countries out of 180 countries
were like 12th the 13th.
That seems pretty bad to me.
Glenn, I appreciate the phone call.
I've got to run.
We're gonna take a quick break.
If you were holding, don't hang up, because
I will go right back to the phones after this